This is a special card.
This is my little girl,
with her hair that she said kept
growing out rather than down
which is how she wanted it to grow.
This is the princess card
that was created
because I couldn’t find it
in the stores.
Motherhood launched my life
in many ways,
certainly launched my career.
I was looking for a card
for my little girl who was seven
and going through this stage
where she didn’t like her hair.
And I went looking
for a greeting card
that would subtly reinforce
her sense of self.
And I thought, "I'll find
a brown-skinned princess"
and realised quickly that
there was a complete absence
of anything that was representative.
And had one of those epiphany
moments where I thought,
"Oh, why don't I do this?"
Rather than discarding the thought
I stepped into it
and it changed my life
because it opened up this entire
entrepreneurial journey
where I realised the power of doing
something which is driven by meaning.
Color blind cards went on
to be, really,
the first independent publisher
to secure a presence for black cards
or multicultural cards
in the British High Street.
We won lots of awards
and got distributed in America
and South Africa.
And started this,
or were certainly part of this
early conversation around
why representation
and diversity and inclusion
are so important in retail.
I'm very proud of that.
When I wake up,
I pick up my pad and my pen
and I just let a stream
of consciousness hit the page
before I start my day.
And it's an opportunity
to check in with myself.
And sometimes it's ideas
and sometimes it's just,
"Really tired, really tired.
Need tea," you know.
I find by the end of this three pages
of writing I'm centred.
And so I'm able to step into my day
really knowing how I'm feeling
and sometimes I have answers
to problems which is just brilliant.
So yeah, I highly recommend it.
I think it's very important
to stop apologising.
And it can be difficult,
it can be really difficult
because we live in a world where
often we're programmed
to feel like there is a certain way
we should be,
a certain way we should behave,
a certain way we should look.
When actually, what we have to offer,
our unique point of difference
is all about who we are.
Because I will always be a woman
who grew up on a council estate,
who is very aware and has family
and friends who are experiencing
or have experienced
the challenges which are a reality
for people of colour,
are a reality for people from lower
socio-economic backgrounds,
and I'm proud of that,
because all of it has contributed
to my unique perspective.
And my unique experience of the world
and that's what makes me who I am.
Two and a half years ago
my dad had been diagnosed
with terminal cancer
and we were very close.
For the first time, really, in my
professional life I stopped doing.
You know, those things
that had felt so critical
and had held so much importance
were put into perspective.
And I guess it just,
sort of, drove home
how important it is for us to
sometimes get off the treadmill.
So what I do is I go on a date
with myself now.
Which is a two hour period
where it's just me,
no distractions of phones
or schedules.
And just a chance to be
with myself and be present.
And I'm still ambitious, I'm still...
It's just driven by something
that's much more healthy,
and that inspires me
on a daily basis.